speaking of someone she's coming back
yeah she's going to do the beam yeah
which is interesting what do you think
about that al um
i don't know really what are so she said
she's like twisties and all the gymnasts
are like oh [ __ ] okay that's serious
could be i don't know what it is what is
it uh it's almost like um
when you're in a slump in baseball so
it's like it's not that you're not good
anymore it's just you're so
in your head that like all your talent
is just like gone
yeah it's like the yep they talk about
in golf where you could be same thing
the twisties i guess from what i was
trying to read you don't know like where
your body's not doing what you wanted to
mentally in midair at the peak of the
jump
so you could get seriously injured yeah
and i think it does make sense that she
landed off that one
horribly and then she just looked shaken
up and then just got the [ __ ] just
walked off
like i think she was like dude i think i
might almost just died right there like
my body wasn't doing i wanted to
walked up yeah i don't know if it goes
away that quickly though i'm worried for
her
that's a thing i learned a little bit
more about this so basically um during
qualifying she was having issues like
she wasn't performing at her best i saw
that
didn't just happen and leading up to
qualifying she was like i just can't
wait for the olympics to be over because
i want to retire
yeah she was she was checked
yeah so now it's like i get it now and
so that the thing
what you said uh this what's it called
skips or twist twist
so it's like you lose your um you lose
where you are in the air
and so she's been gifted to have that
ability since she was six
her very first like flip she just knew
how to do it
and they were like this is crazy like no
problem has
this ability at this young so she's
always been that good and it just came
to her
so now the fact happened to not have it
this is the first time dealing with that
it's like
she said it's happened before and it's
been a one to two week
period where it took to get it away
yeah another thing that's worth noting
with this [ __ ] is like it is
objectively more dangerous than other
sports right oh there's so much more
yeah like whenever people compare it to
like oh well you know this track star
ran with a hurt ankle it's like yeah
that's tough but it's different when
you're yeah
yeah instead of a hurdle you have to
[ __ ] somersault over the hurdle every
time yeah
yeah yeah there's not a lot of people
have been paralyzed around with her too
i think there's a lot of disappointment
initially and i think people are just
kind of coming around i think that that
uh other girl suny lee winning the all
right yeah
yeah and like the team still being
pretty successful i mean i guess they
lost the team gold but they got like
silver like
the team doing okay eased a lot of
people's tensions because it was never
really about simone biles right it was
your selfish yearning to win gold in the
olympics and be better than all these
other countries
yeah so yeah i think that that calm the
down goal what i was saying adds up with
what we were saying last week though
which is she already was kind of ready
to retire she was kind of done with it
then you got this twisty and you're like
i could die on any jump and i don't even
want to be here yeah
i'm done i'm actually yeah i don't know
why she's competing in this unless
this [ __ ] is gone i think it's kind of
cool if she wins this then she gets to
go out and leave yeah
another thing with the beam i guess high
risk maybe they just realized oh it's
not as dangerous as like flipping
through the air like doing like
the vault or whatever like yeah with
beam like if you fall off you just fall
on the ground
or like yeah there's something to catch
you she might be
they might be able to evaluate the risk
and realize it's not as risky yeah yeah
or maybe she's just really confident in
that
one thing so i'm surprised that she
didn't want to do the floor
because the floor to me is the one that
seems the the least risky
and that's where she has her move that
no one else can do it's on the floor
it's called the body
i saw her during the warm-up or whatever
like the qualifying thing
but you could you could honestly see you
were like oh i didn't know it was a
mental thing or what but like she
doesn't look like she's
like even the commentators like she
doesn't look like she normally looks
she's still
the best but she doesn't look like she
normally lives
i feel bad yeah did we ever talk about
the scoring thing with her yeah
yeah like how uh they didn't adjust it
yeah yeah
yeah and do you think that's part of the
reason why she wanted the floor where
she's like
i'm gonna get [ __ ] on the scoring
anyway or like i can't even work that i
can't even do this [ __ ] i want to do i'm
already pissed about this
specific event maybe maybe i mean i
thought was really interesting was the
uh this little conspiracy theory going
around that like the adderall
not being able to get i've heard that
yeah you heard about this
i didn't hear this so i guess adderall
is illegal in japan
yeah okay so not that it's illegal for
olympic competition but i think it's
just illegal in japan
so some people are saying she wasn't
able to be on adderall and that
was you know causing the twisting
apparently apparently she has had hdhd
since since she was a kid
yeah so and some people say that that's
like a uh i mean adderall is amazing
yeah you know i know we all know it like
allows
singular focus also it is it is on the
banned substance list for the olympics
oh it is yeah according to this article
well she's been with
ban sub this but not the other that's
what i heard yeah this abc news
headlines just says adhd meds among
common drugs banned from olympics i can
believe that
it's banned from the olympics because of
japanese because it's in japan
i think not olympic law go oh i would
also think maybe if she's had the
prescription since she was a child it's
like
you could go back and make an exception
if it was banned for the olympics then
it's null and void right because she's
competed once without it before so it
doesn't matter
but my understanding was it was
specifically in japan and
what no because the story came up in
2016 also it was like a big story in
2016.
and she couldn't take it she couldn't
get it then also
that's when a lot of these articles
about like the adhd meds with simone
biles came out
mmm interesting if you already competed
and it worked out fine then that's just
a [ __ ] conspiracy theory
uh which terror critic she's not saying
we haven't heard that from her yeah i
saw one thing in the olympics i thought
was quite interesting and
kind of like indicative of uh super cup
culture that's going on right now but
i'm curious your guys perspective
um the high jump you guys are familiar
with this
uh event the high jump it's where they
kind of do like a
almost a backflip over the bar yeah i
saw this
and so there's two uh competitors right
a guy from italy and a guy from qatar
and they've been competing i think it
was like two hours or something like
this at this point in time
and they both do the same height and
then they both
miss the height after that and the judge
comes up to them and they goes you guys
can do a jump off
or i guess you guys keep jumping until
one misses
or you got and then and then the qatari
guy goes
can we share gold and then the ref goes
if he wants to and then they look at
each other and i think they were
training partners so they had like a
relationship
and uh the italian guy goes yes and just
jumps and embraces the qatari guy
and then both of them go and they're
sharing the gold medal
what do you guys think about that
weirdly i wasn't as upset
initially i hated it and then when you
said they trained together in their
homies i'm not as bothered but
i still you just [ __ ] win man just go
win be a winner
you know what's interesting does that
count as two goals i think it counts as
two goals two goals in a bronze
i guess so but what's interesting about
it is uh
okay from like a financial standpoint
they both know that like being a gold
medalist is so much more lucrative you
go back to your country
there's not that many golds from guitar
i can imagine 100 yeah right
at least ones they didn't buy i think
remember they were like buying
weightlifters or something like that
like they would get all these like
georgian from
the country of georgia yeah like guys to
just like go and get citizenship
immediately and all of a sudden
they're doing that for the world cup
that's going to be out there they've
been doing it for years
so uh so yes so essentially what i
thought was interesting about this and
why i understood it a little bit more
is in high jump
you're competing with the bar
not really competing against a person
right it's not wrestling or
yes wrestling that kind of stuff like if
both you look like should we both share
the goal it's like
no no every day you're training to beat
the person across from you and ping pong
you beat the person across from you and
fencing you beat the person across them
it's like
your mind is geared towards domination
whereas
high jump you don't even need the other
person to be there or not
like you could just show up at four
o'clock and then try to beat the number
and then you beat it sure if you don't
like you're really not competing against
another person
you're competing for this this specific
height
that you're trying to jump to so i do
understand why they have a different
camaraderie
than other sports like a tennis for
example where it's like i am trying to
break
you yeah i want to break your will and i
won't use mental tactics i'll use
anything i can to break
you down because you're returning
something at me
that i have to do so usually at first my
my initial reaction i'm like oh this is
some [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean you're at the
olympics shouldn't you want to [ __ ]
go for victory go for gold
and then i was like in a weird way like
i'm like financially they're both gonna
do so much [ __ ] better i
kind of get it i'm my [ __ ] for
understanding it i agree with financial
but here's where i push back on that
take well he said yeah
yeah here's where i push back on that
part about competing
maybe the greatest winner we've ever had
in sports is tiger woods yeah and he
never competed against anybody
one-on-one after return when you get
it's golf i go you go
i'm gonna [ __ ] crush you anytime it
matters i'm gonna win
everybody in the [ __ ] field needs to
know this so that's where i push back
because golf is we might even really
call it a sport but it's the same thing
it's just you and the club and that's it
who who has the best score
question yeah i just don't consider
going to a tie at the end of golf is
there a penalty
no you go you keep going you have like
um sudden death or whatever you do one
more hole
and then whoever does better on that one
two more holes whatever it is they have
a winner especially
like tournament grand slams you're not
you're not doing major that's that's a
sport there's no tie for
like if if a tie and then you just gotta
like do a guessing game on kicks to end
the game yeah that's that
that's not really a sport but golf sport
i can say that's what a guessing
that's how soccer is yeah it really is
yeah that's a good point all right fair
enough but um
it is hey that's my homie and we're both
gonna make a lot of money or we could go
back and live and [ __ ] wherever we're
gonna live and
struggle for the rest of our lives if we
both get gold that's great and also the
game
is not how many times you can jump this
high
the game is how high you can jump if you
both can reach a certain height
and that's as high as you both can get i
understand it right like it
uh endurance doesn't really play much
into high jump
right it's not really mental exactly or
or physical in terms of your endurance
like
it's not like hey we're going to keep
doing this until somebody's leg gives
out no it's
how high can you get oh you got nine
feet or whatever it is
i got nine feet i know i've never done
better than nine feet you know you've
never done better than nine feet
we both delivered our best jump on the
day
yeah i don't really blame the athletes
like because in my mind i'm like
their job is to get gold and they were
basically given a deal where they could
get gold so yeah
they kind of did what they were supposed
to do i'm more suspect of like the
olympic committee that's like
yeah we'll just give multiple golds out
to whoever
i think the fault falls on like the
olympic committee for like devaluing the
price of their own goals yeah being like
yeah anyway yeah if you guys agree you
know if you guys can
there's slight tuckiness to the
competitiveness because i guarantee you
if we're trying to touch an awning
you want to get higher than your homies
like there's not like oh we got the same
height great nah [ __ ] that
raise it up yeah get a higher awning
whatever yeah why do they make it
jumping backwards over just make it
touch an awning like that's the most
that should be the olympic sport like
everybody does that that's the olympic
sport in new york
yes touching that [ __ ] i got that [ __ ]
off of two legs or one
like that's always the conversation you
offer two you can do it off the vert
don't step into it do it off the verge
that's true like that is a way more
relatable sport
jump high can you jump high good hit it
like the combine
it's the combine yeah yeah yeah
backwards jump and [ __ ] like long arms
long arms playing a lot for touch the
awning that's another thing long arms
make up for the fact that you might not
be able to get something that's your
body yeah yeah
that's the advantage but yeah i put it
on the olympic community i don't really
put on the athletes so much
because i get their position like but
it's the olympics
job to push the athletes and be like nah
we're going until someone wins
and then that's where the athlete's
gotta be like all right i gotta push
through yeah yeah
yeah i get it